this video is sponsored by one day
university
if you're anything of a film buff this
scene from wes anderson's moonrise
kingdom might seem familiar to you
but why wes anderson despite being one
of the most visually unique directors
working today
pax's films full of references and
homage
i've talked about how blatant at times
these can be like how he recreates an
entire scene from a hitchcock film in
the grand budapest hotel
but sometimes where a film reference
came from isn't so blatantly obvious
and unless a director tells us
specifically what inspired something
trying to discover the origin of a scene
can lead us down quite a rabbit trail
the origin of some references is pretty
clear this shot
definitely seems to be a callback to
eyes wide shut
[Music]
this moment
[Applause]
jiminy cricket he flew the coop is an
homage to the shawshank redemption
[Music]
this line take the carbon leave the
bible is a modification
of this one from the godfather leave the
gun
take the cannoli a reference reinforced
by the fact that actor jason
schwartzman's mother
talia shire was in the godfather in
moonrise kingdom
and close encounters of the third kind
bob balaban plays a character who
interrupts a discussion with the same
line
excuse me
excuse me excuse me captain sharp
close encounters of the third kind also
has some stylistic influence on the way
west shot clouds for moonrise kingdom in
moonrise kingdom the character redford
bears a resemblance to
robert redford with some examples the
line between a reference
and inspiration gets a little blurry the
look of the rooftop scene at the end of
moonrise kingdom was probably inspired
by the look of this rooftop scene from
the original mary poppins
in melody a british film from 1971 that
has a young boy and girl running away
together
the paramilitary boys group in the
beginning you've been drinking onshore
nasha was probably inspiration for the
way the khaki scouts are portrayed in
moonrise kingdom
your socks are down your shirt tails are
untucked your trousers are not properly
pressed
you are reported for a uniform violation
i saw one person online suggest that
this scene of the dam breaking was
inspired by this shot from
shining
anderson's use of abstraction to convey
violence in this scene
seems heavily inspired by the way
jean-luc godard does the same thing in
la shinosei
[Music]
and purolofu
[Music]
a film by the way that also has a man
and a woman on the run
camped out in a cove by the sea reading
books sometimes i think wes
is clearly trying to point a finger back
at a specific character line or moment
in another film
and other times it seems more like he
just likes a specific technique or
idea and uses it in his own way but
who's to say for example this scene from
the 1970 film the honeymoon killers
i must confess to you your charming
letters have cheered my life
dear raymond thanks for your picture you
are exactly as i
imagined here is one of me oh it doesn't
do me justice
i want you to call me ray only one woman
ever did that
was clearly an inspiration for this
scene from moonrise kingdom
dear susie one dear sam where
dear susie walk 400 yards but i don't
think it looks like wes
is trying to make an obvious reference
to the film
and other times it seems like he's
making a reference but
the exact origin of that reference is a
little unclear
is the dummy in this scene a reference
to
the dummy and ferris bueller's day off
or is it a reference to escape from
alcatraz which used a dummy years before
that
what about susie's binoculars
are susie's binoculars as some suggest a
reference to luke's binoculars in star
wars
but i don't see any wait a second or
are they a reference to james stewart's
character in hitchcock's rear window
or does the reference fit better with
the 1964 film charlata
here the binoculars are an expression of
the character's loneliness
which seems to fit closely with suzy's
character in moonrise kingdom
moonrise kingdom the most mysterious
case
is this scene online i found someone who
suggested it was a reference to the
famous scene from pulp fiction
and while it does bear a resemblance
someone else mentioned that it was
probably a reference instead to
the scene that inspired the scene in
pulp fiction
the dancing scene and gadarz aband apart
this could be but it's worth mentioning
that it also resembles
this scene from terence malik's
[Music]
the badlands from badlands has a lot to
suggest is perhaps the true source it's
about two characters hiding in the woods
and the two girls even seem to have
similar eye makeup
as a fan of wes anderson and malik's
work i've been aware of the connection
between these two
films for a while but recently i was
working on a video about ingmar bergman
and i watched his film my summer with
monica
in this film a young boy and girl run
off together
and they stake their claim in a little
cove along the sea
and in the midst of a story and a
scenario that is already very similar to
moonrise kingdoms
we find this scene
[Music]
so which film is wes referencing in
moonrise kingdom
i don't have a definitive answer for you
if wes had one of these specific scenes
in mind he hasn't said
most likely he was aware of all of them
when he was crafting this scene
in a sense i think wes is less trying to
point a finger back
to a specific scene that came before and
more just
including his film in a body of work
with similar moments
but are these kind of references just
fun little easter eggs or do they serve
a purpose
within the storytelling well in wes's
case i think his
style overall is very much about
creating a self-aware sense
of being told a story by the filmmaker
clear allusions to other films feed into
that aesthetic reminding us that we're
watching
a movie and it's another example of the
fingerprints of the storyteller being
left on the film
something i talk about in my video about
wes's style
but i think a lot of these references
can also serve a broader purpose as well
wes usually doesn't just rip a stylistic
idea and
apply it somewhere else mindlessly the
moment where he applies the reference
and the moment he's referencing
tend to align thematically or
emotionally
take susie's binoculars if you know the
reference wes is making your knowledge
of that story about a woman who feels
lonely and isolated
will actually inform your understanding
of susie as a character
or if you made the connection between
moonrise's climactic scene
and mary poppins the fantastical fairy
tale elements of mary poppins reinforces
the almost
magical storybook ending of moonrise
kingdom
some people are suspicious of this kind
of thing thinking that someone like wes
is just ripping off the work of others
and there certainly is a line that can
be crossed
but the key is crafting references in a
way that rewards
rather than punishes the audience for
knowing the source material
and is respectful to the origin of the
idea or image that you're borrowing
if you're borrowing inspiration from
another scene does it add depth to yours
will the audience's memory of the story
you're calling back to add
richness to the current experience are
you remixing it
and adding to it or will the audience
just think not again
and be bored so if you're gonna steal
steal like wes
steal from the best seeing how a movie
like moonrise kingdom references all
these films in the past can be
a great introduction to just how rich
and interesting film history can be
and if you want to learn more about film
history from an actual film professor to
check out the lecture four films that
changed america using my sponsor
one day university one day university is
a platform that hosts
live lectures from top rated professors
from universities all around the country
every weekday and they also have a back
catalog of over 500 lectures you can
listen to on a variety of topics not
just
film but arts business history and
politics
and psychology i already mentioned the
four films that changed america lecture
from mark lapadula
at yale university but you might also
enjoy his lecture about the genius of
alfred hitchcock or the lecture from
jonathan
kuntz at ucla new hollywood how digital
captured the industry
you can check out these lectures and
other great lectures from universities
like stanford
yale and duke when you sign up for a one
month free trial
using the link in the description after
that free trial memberships are 8.95 a
month or 89
a year but if you use the code
thomasflight you can get half off that
annual membership so you get a full year
of great lectures for only 45
click that link to sign up for your one
month free trial and get started
learning today
thanks again so much to one day you for
sponsoring this video and if you like
this video
check out my other videos about wes
[Music]
anderson